puis elle nicolas vidal directeur de
publication de putsch mais doit nous a
rejoint nicolas vidal bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
alors on l'entendait on entendait un ces
témoignages les gens venus défendre le
métier de journaliste mais pas seulement
c'est aussi défendre les citoyens tous
les citoyens selon vous à cette
manifestation un bus et aime pas de
mouvement social a une nouvelle fois
vous me direz une fois de plus je
devrais parler que s'ils avaient été des
lourds à qui avait été passé une loi ou
des dispositifs qui avait été bâti en
hongrie en pologne
quelques n'aurait pas entendu ici en
france sur un état totalitaire qui
versait dans la dictature
alain fort du saas en france verra quand
on analyse solide à votre question je
pense qu'un niveau d'acceptabilité
aujourd'hui des mesures qui ne partent
plus il est proportionnel à la
légitimité de la parole publique et
politique
donc aujourd'hui vous voyez je vous
donne un exemple de terrain se
maintenant à gta mont pelé ce que je
suis à montpellier je suis à la
manifestation non plus il y avait
énormément de monde et c'est exactement
pluriel il y avait des professeurs des
enseignants des journalistes ont entendu
des citoyens en colère
donc on voit qu'aujourd'hui ces
mesures-là entre le schéma vous savez le
nouvel ordre
le schéma de maintien de leur ardeur
nationale et cette fameuse loi de
sécurité globale il n'y a pas de
consentement populaire sur ce genre de
dispositif soit la loi soit le
dispositif imposé par gérald darmanin
donc à partir de là on est ainsi dans
cette loi parce que je vous rappelle
olivier de ce qu'avait dit gérald
darmanin mercredi dernier en conférence
de presse suite à la soirée très
mouvementée de mardi soir boulevard
saint-jean mais ont plusieurs confrères
notamment régulier qui avait été un peu
molesté par les par débordement ou notre
confrère de transport
le conte 3 pardon et d'un autre
aujourd'hui on a du mal à faire notre
boulot et il y avait dit effectivement
pour être en sécurité ils avaient convié
les journalistes à se tourner vers la
préfecture de police de paris je ne
crois pas qu'aujourd'hui pour faire le
travail qu'on va partager une interview
d'articles nous ayons besoin de se
tourner vers la préfecture du secteur
pour pouvoir travailler
donc oui c'est loi aujourd'hui elles
sont extrêmement dérangeante façon
inquiétante
lyon est en train de s'éloigner comme ça
petit à petit dérives de la démocratie
et je vais vous le dire tout de go je
suis très inquiet effectivement de ce
qui se passe et je suis aussi avec un
peu d'espoir aux milliers de cette
mobilisation citoyenne autour de cette
loi qui a été votée par très réputé
finalement hier soir
alors cette loi elle vise pour le
gouvernement selon gouvernement à la
protection des forces de l'ordre
néanmoins ace qu'il y aurait eu il
aurait été possible de trouver un autre
équilibre finalement entre la liberté
d'informer et celle de protéger des
forces de l'ordre oui en tout cas pour
avoir écouté je me suis renseigné bien
entendu je suis à lire le texte de loi
scrutin public
je pense y avait des choses à faire on
aurait pu bien entendu essayé de faire
autrement
et puis le prouve le code pénal est
assez riche le code pénal et affine
danse me semble-t-il je pense qu'il faut
savoir l'appliquer et puis une note
notons quelque chose pourquoi il n'est
pas apparu dans les amendements par
exemple le port obligatoire du herriot
ce que demandait si les jeunes et les
manifestants d'avoir plus que les sites
des jeunes le port de sète numéro
d'identification qui permet un moment
donné si on estime avoir et il
un pardon de violences policières
finalement invité roger y arriver lui
ans messieurs on peut se tourner vers
vers le coeur de la république ou vers
l'intérieur ou vers l'hygiène donc
honorer pur pour répondre aux questions
auraient pu effectivement mettre en
place leur immobilier pas
malheureusement apparemment il est déjà
obligatoire mais ce n'est pas le cas et
je crois que nous pouvons compter
d'aujourd'hui a suffisamment de de
liberté là dessus pouvoir sanctionner
les gens qui se prête à des actes
délictueux d'aller identifier les
policiers pour aller vite harcelée dans
le sein dans le cadre avant de leur vie
privée
voilà un peu ce que l'on aurait pu
imaginer mais vraiment dans le fond du
problème le fond de sauce
aujourd'hui c'est que cette loi elle est
absolument liberticide je l'avais déjà
parlé sur votre antenne concernant le
nouveau schéma du maintien de l'ordre
dire on ne peut pas voir cette loi sans
se référer à ce nouveau schéma du min
est mort parce que finalement c'est une
perspective et une articulation
c'est une cohérence absolue sur la
restriction de la liberté d'informer et
de filmer pour les citoyens qui veulent
rendre et filmer ce qui se passe dans
les manifestations et g77 intentions
liberticide est ce qu'elle est réel
selon vous de la part du gouvernement ou
alors on est plutôt face à une forme de
maladresse d'improvisation finalement
d'amateurisme du gouvernement mais comme
j'aimerais ça soit d'amateurisme et
comme j'aimerais que la toile
l'amateurisme jolie la vente forcée en
direct je lisais un article de mediapart
qui nous informer sur sur le fait que
plusieurs médias européens et quelques
médias américains s'inquiéter de cette
dérive
donc c'est par mois nicolas vidal ou des
journalistes corporatif recrues sur
eux-mêmes pour défendre jalousement
leurs droits je crois que c'est une
vraie question ce conte ce pacte à cela
m'autorise malheureusement je me dis
j'aurais aimé cet amateurisme
mais là je pense que c'est vraiment une
mise en place d'une stratégie
liberticide je le répète dès septembre
2009 le nouveau maintien bull
le méthane ou lors du gauche schéma
pardon du maintien de l'ordre et
maintenant cette fameuse loi d'ailleurs
on a vu que gérald ramin à rétropédaler
rapidement seul article 24 de stars
martin 24 et je demande vraiment à tous
ceux qui nous regardent d'année lire le
texte notamment à les lire le texte
également lecture publique bien sûr sur
le site de l'année à ce mal il faut se
rendre compte on peut extraire l'indiqué
est sur le terrain j'ai fini par là sur
le terrain j'ai pu avoir du mal nous on
est très habitués à faire de la
manifestation les habitués au terrain
très sincèrement on va voir comment ça
va se passer d'ailleurs plusieurs
journalistes de rendre visite au rallye
de médias main stream grande presse se
sont indignés publiquement sur twitter
donc quand ces gens commencent à celles
dignes et ce qui a vraiment pour
reprendre une expression populaire et
triviale que j'aime bien il ya vraiment
le feu au lac et vous vous parlais
justement de l'amendement de l'article
24 du gouvernement qui a inclus des
dispositions visant à protéger le droit
d'informer pourquoi c'est ce n'est pas
suffisant pour calmer le jeu parce que
comme je le disais hier à berlin il a
déjà fait une boulette mercredi avec ça
et puis c'est surtout ça veut pas calmer
le jeu parce qu on est sur le terrain on
se rend bien compte
l'application de la loi est compliqué je
pars est à la rue heriot le voyez votre
numéro obligatoire que les ports de
l'ordre à coup il se leva voire même les
gendarmes
et puis on se rend compte qu'aujourd'hui
c'est très compliqué déjà c'était
compétir dans la loi alors imaginez vous
à partir de quand on entend tout ça
quand le processus législatif sera allé
à son terme
comment ça respect qu'elle passait sur
le terrain réellement et très
sincèrement je pense que ça va être
compliqué et aujourd'hui cet article 24
c'est un article extrêmement corrosif
très corrosif pour la liberté d'informer
dans la liberté d'expression de fait si
vous pouvez plus informé parce que vous
devez fuir
je rappelle rapidement que sur ce schéma
du maintien de l'or ce nouveau schéma du
maintien de l'ordre dont un commissaire
de police tu donnes des sommations vous
journalistes vous êtes obligés de fuir
également de vous car à pattes et comme
les manifestants sous peine d'être
interpellés mis en garde à vue ce n'est
pas normal vidéo on est là pour faire
votre boulot on n'est pas là pour à
entraver ce que je leur permis de les
chercher un policier n'est pas à prendre
avec travail des forces de l'anp c'est
pas notre boulot on est là pour informer
les gens en direct en prenant des
risques des gens de manifestations et de
voir un moment donné c'est dit aux
injonctions de dispersion les policiers
font un travail mais nous aussi
hormis sur les manifestations aux gays
faire un travail on vient d'informer les
gens donc tout cela est en train de nous
en travée de but et c'est extrêmement
inquiétante attendant je suis je suis
vraiment très très inquiet je viens sur
authie contre 7,7 loi et comment ce
nouveau schéma du maintien de l'ordre
on vient d'entendre à dominique pradalié
la secrétaire général du syndicat
national des journalistes dire que cette
loi est bien elle est faite pour museler
la presse et que finalement elle répond
simplement aux syndicats de policiers
les plus ultras vous rejoignez ses
propos effectivement il ya une perte de
nette en droit c'est évident il faut il
faut quand même il faut quand même le
voir donc ça a été le complotisme ça a
été la sédition rappelez vous la faction
les factieux pour les jeunes après ça a
été le complotisme concernant toutes les
questions médicales sur cette fameuse
qu'ovide havel hydroxy chloroquine ou
pas dire aussi que roque inra auparavant
donc on a eu cette accusation de
complotisme ses montées au climax avec
ce documentaire très controversé qui
était hold up est aujourd'hui bon mais
on essaie effectivement de rogner ce que
nous la presse indépendante même fait
des ventes peut faire comme comme
pluralisme des mois pour essayer de dire
aux citoyens bon voilà il ya plus tard
tim n'hésitez pas à aller lire et à voir
s'il en est je vous le disais tout à
l'heure olivier aujourd'hui avec
plusieurs journalistes de presse
mainstream et même tribune qui est paru
dans france info c'est si les grands
médias les grandes rédactions qui samedi
on peut pas les accuser d'avoir un
comportement anti gouvernementales à
l'heure
édito d'alors traitement de
l'information donc à un moment donné
même si eux ils montent au créneau avec
nous parce que nous ça fait un petit
moment qu'on monte au créneau donc ils
sont là à côté de nous avec beaucoup de
retard serbes ils sont là on peut pas on
peut quand même dire qu'il ya une
certaine unanimité hors de la sphère
parlementaire vient de l'exécutive
l'exécutif pardon pour dire quel poste
cette loi ne pose des problèmes et elle
est profondément liberticide
donc c'est si c'est vraiment un scandale
et oui je rejoins quelque 40 parties
quelques propos de dominique pradalié
bien entendu en tant que journaliste
indépendant et je lui qui veut rester
libre et ne pas avoir téléphoné à mêler
à la préfecture pour savoir si je peux
faire une interview un article non je ne
ferais je ne tournerai jamais vers la
préfecture pour bosser ça fait 13 ans
que je fais ça et je le pourrai pas
c'est pas demain la veille que je le
ferai merci beaucoup
nicolas vidal directeur de la
publication de putsch médias d'avoir
réagir en direct avec nous sur notre
antenne